the White House releases models
suggesting at least 100,000 Americans
could die in the corona virus pandemic
the Fed continues to pump dollars into
the economy and partisanship continues
to rear its ugly head I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
I bet in Shapiro show is sponsored by
Express at VPN why have you not gotten a
VPN yet you're on the internet all the
time people want your data get a VPN now
visit expressive VPN comm /ban that's
expressvpn comm /ban alright so let's
just jump right into the corona virus
updates so as of yesterday this is
according to world ometer the united
states experienced nearly a thousand new
deaths from corona virus we're now in
excess of 4,000 deaths in the United
States from a corona virus we had the
biggest single-day tally of death that
is not unexpected we are expecting those
numbers to rise presumably according to
the models every day up until April 15th
tax day the United States already has
close to 200,000 cases that have been
diagnosed in the United States and we
are starting to see all of the emergency
situations in hospitals coming to
fruition although we have not yet been
forced to ration ventilators the
situation in ers particularly in New
York is very ugly Seth Manziel who is
the editor over the Washington Examiner
magazine he he just got a note from a
doctor friend in Queens as I spent 24 of
the last 36 hours in my er it's an
absolute nightmare
I personally intubated three patients in
just under an hour we have over 400
patients admitted with coronavirus 82 of
them are on ventilators to put things in
perspective my er is built to have about
80 to 100 patients we had 172 people
admitted with Koba 19 crabbed in two
spots corners crevices all of our ICU
and step-down units together can usually
handle 50 patients we are managing
ventilators in hallways now again
managing ventilators in hallways is
still better than no ventilators but it
is obviously insufficient to deal with
the influx of people who are being
admitted to hospitals and ers in the New
York Region in 22 years of Medicine says
this doctor I've never seen the staff
look this tired physically and
emotionally drained at least twice an
hour we hear the call overhead that
somebody upstairs in cardiac arrest this
acutely exacerbates our distress people
we were caring for our dead 12 hours
later 30 year olds 50 year olds
seven-year-olds nobody is spared now at
this point is worthy of mention well if
you go into the ER there's a good shot
that there are at least a better shot
that there is something seriously wrong
with you in terms of people across the
country who are getting coronavirus and
then getting significant symptoms if
you're older if you have pre-existing
conditions that's where the real risk
lies this doctor says we're at the
breaking point we're out of space in our
Hospital we're out of space in the
emergency room I was caring for a woman
with an oxygen level of 64% I had to
have her sitting in a chair for an
our until I could find a stretcher
multiple doctors in the hospital are out
sick with the virus I'm caring for
patients in their homes as long as their
oxygen level is above 90% I'm trying to
keep them from going to the hospital
so obviously grim news out of New York
we are seeing some trend lines from
places like New Orleans that are looking
fairly ugly we're seeing some trend
lines from Florida that are looking
fairly ugly the trend lines in places
like Los Angeles or not nearly as ugly
yet in San Francisco the trend lines
have evened out to a significant extent
the social distancing is working those
measures that have been put in place we
are seeing the sort of contrasting data
you would expect to see highly populated
areas that took a little longer to walk
down are seeing trend lines that are a
lot uglier than areas that are sparsely
populated and or are locked down more
often and to pretend that every single
area of the United States should be
treating this equivalently is foolhardy
obviously if you're in a rural area
we're not seeing tons of people on a
daily basis you shouldn't be treating
this exactly the same way you would if
you're living in a heavily populated
area like New York City but even in
Europe you're starting to see the
differential data emerge from places
like Sweden Netherlands Denmark places
that are locking down in northern Europe
are seeing the curve start to flatten
places like Sweden are seeing the curve
start to steepen so obviously the social
distancing measures are in fact
effective but now does that mean that in
the end when all is said and done the
social distancing measures will have
been worth wrecking the entire world
economy we don't know yet I mean frankly
all we can do at this point is go on the
best available data and that's what
these models that were presented by the
White House yesterday are that's that's
really what it comes down to so
yesterday over at the White House the
the what the the Trump administration
laid out some models for what is going
to happen going forward President Trump
announced that this is going to be
painful there there's gonna be painful
weeks and months ahead this obviously is
true reality has set in for the Trump
administration but it's been set in for
about three weeks now we're starting to
see all the recriminations from the
partisans in the media who are
suggesting well if Trump had just been
on top of this in late January then
everything would have been different
well listen it would be great if the
Trump administration had been overseeing
the CDC with regard to testing a lot
earlier and a lot better it also
would've been great if three successive
administrations had not ignored all of
the requests for building up ventilator
and hospital bed capacity that would
been really good also it would have been
great if the Democrats had not been
downplaying it at the same time as Trump
and
I'm getting kind of sick of the sort of
timeline politics that are being played
right here where Democrats were calling
for a full lockdown in late January
that's not true if Donald Trump in
January 28th when he issued the China
travel ban and said not only my barring
travel from China also we needed to week
lockdowns that we can ramp up testing in
the United States you think Democrats
would have gone along with that is there
any shot at all that Democrats would
have gone along with it
Vox was running pieces in late January
about how this was the seasonal flu so
let's be real about the fact that nobody
knew anything
in late January sufficient to take the
most drastic step in the history of the
American economy and in the history of
American government in a non wartime
scenario let's it let's be real about
the timeline let's be real about
imperfect knowledge in times of
imperfect knowledge let's also be real
about the way that the media are
treating some of these death tolls so
you're seeing a lot of headlines today
things like the United States could be
on pace to lose more people than the
Vietnam War that we that yesterday we
surpassed the death toll from 9/11 yes
because these diseases are not like wars
or like terrorist attacks you idiots
okay there's a lot of talk about how
this is not like the flu that's true
it's not like the flu it's like the flu
in that it is a disease it is not like
the flu in that it has a much higher
transmissibility rate and presumably a
higher death rate although the estimates
range from around flu rates to ten times
flu rates and those are those estimates
vary ranging from doctor j Bhattacharya
from Stanford who says this is gonna
look like seasonal flu when it comes to
the final fatality rate to the folks
over at Imperial College you think that
it's around 1% but with all of that said
to compare this to Vietnam is idiotic to
compare this to 911 is idiotic I mean if
we're if we're going to do disease tolls
as compared to Wars then let's just be
straight about the flu itself the fluid
self on in a bad year will kill 58,000
60,000 people in a bad year in the
United States that's as many as we lost
during the entire Vietnam War II never
saw any headlines about how the flu is
our new Vietnam that's not the way this
works a disease as a disease it requires
really strict treatment right now but to
compare it to terrorist attacks or the
Vietnam War which were in large part
political failures is just ignorant okay
what we are watching right here is a
pandemic washing through the population
and taking out a lot of people not even
one compared to something compared to
the Spanish flu from 1918 you want to
compare to something compared to the
1958 Hong Kong flu right if you want to
compare it to something compared to SARS
compared to other diseases you idiots
this is a category error
do not compare it to wars wars are not
the same thing pottery and wars is not
quite the same thing as we have a
shortage of insulator supplies and we
are all doing our best to get those
ventilators out there and also we have
to stay home yeah that is not the same
thing
in any way shape or form and your media
who are so determined to turn this into
a political disaster as opposed to just
a human disaster are making a very
large-scale mistake okay we're gonna get
to what exactly President Trump said
yesterday we're gonna get to all of the
modeling and we're going to get to some
more data talking about who is actually
the most vulnerable in all of this we'll
get to all of that momentarily first
let's talk about the reality the reality
of the situation is that we like to make
the most out of our day we like to make
sure that we can get all of our exercise
in during the day we also like to make
sure that we can toss and turn all night
April Fool's haha no you want a you want
a mattress that actually is going to
give you what you need you know mattress
personalized for you I'm talking about a
helix sleep mattress like right now you
want to lie down and just go to sleep I
don't blame you man what you need is a
helix sleep mattress that is gonna be
incredibly comfortable this comes as a
father of three with a brand new newborn
would I lie down on that mattress I want
to be comfortable and the only way for
that to happen for me is to have a
mattress made just for me this is helix
sleep helix sleep has a quiz it takes
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you whether you're
a side sleeper hot sleeper with you like
a plush or a firm bed with helix there's
no more confusion no more compromising
helix sleep it's rated the number one
mattress by GQ and Wired magazine CNN
called it the most comfortable mattress
they've ever slept on and that time CNN
was telling the truth
they've got a 10-year warranty you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it you will it's a great
mattress and you're gonna be spending a
lot of time on that mattress since
you're at home a lot helix is offering
up to 200 bucks off all mattress orders
for our listeners go check them out
right now get up to 200 bucks off at
helix sleep comm slash Ben that is helix
sleep comm slash Ben he looks sleep calm
slash Ben go check them out right now
get up to 200 bucks off okay so
president Trump yesterday he gives this
press conference at the White House and
he says this is going to be a very very
rough couple of weeks we can have some
rough weeks and months ahead this
obviously is true I want every American
to be prepared for the hard days that
lie ahead we're going to go through a
very tough two weeks
and then hopefully as the experts are
predicting as I think a lot of us are
predicting after having studied it's so
hard you're gonna start seeing some real
light at the end of the tunnel but this
is going to be a very painful very very
painful two weeks when you look and see
at night the kind of death that's been
caused by this invisible enemy it's it's
incredible
it is indeed distressing and that that
was a very rough press conference
yesterday I mean it was a useful press
conference but it was a rough press
conference because it was finally the
acknowledgement that a lot of people are
going to die from this according to the
modeling president Trump did go out of
his way to praise doctors and nurses
again I've been doing that every day on
the program to registered nurses
respiratory therapists doctors even the
people who are who are just cleaning the
rooms at the hospitals I mean these are
people who are taking their lives into
their hands
it's one of the reasons we got to
expedite the the creation of the of the
masks and the personal protective
equipment
there's president from yesterday
praising the doctors and the nurses and
I watched the doctors and the nurses
walking into that hospital this morning
it's like military people going into
battle going into war the bravery is
incredible and I just have to take my
hat I would take my head if I were
wearing I had I'd rip that hat off so
fast and I would say you people are just
incredible they really are they're very
brave okay meanwhile President Trump did
finally say coronavirus is not the flu
that comes several weeks after he said
that it was very much like the flu now
to be real Vox also as I say Vox is a
left-wing outlet run by Ezra Klein nice
guy we had him on Sunday special a
voxcom in late January was saying that
this was like the flu they ended up
deleting that suite and it depends on
what you mean by like the flu I mean I
don't mean to be a lawyer here but it
does I mean this is a virus it is a it
is a very grave very serious virus it
does spread like the flu only more so it
is more deadly than the flu so if you're
saying it's like the flu as in it is
just exactly like the flu like Yorick
waiting them that's true that that's not
true at all
if you are saying that it is disease
like the flu that is certainly more
accurate than saying it's like Vietnam
or 9/11 anyway here's President Trump
acknowledging finally
that coronavirus is not like the flu and
listen he's been on this track for weeks
now you know but I don't think anybody
in the country really believes the
corona viruses like the flu that's why
we're all in our houses right now here's
President Trump a lot of people have
said a lot of people have thought about
it write it out don't do anything just
right there and think of it as the flu
but it's not the food it's vicious when
you send a friend to the hospital and
you call up to find out how is he doing
it happened to me where goes to the
hospital he says goodbye sort of a tough
guy a little older a little heavier then
he'd like to be frankly and you go up
the next day how's he doing and he's in
a coma this is not the flu yeah
obviously President Trump is is correct
about this dr. Anthony pouchy he got up
and he said okay well let's just let's
just lay it out on the table we expect
between a hundred thousand and two
hundred forty thousand debts and that
includes the mitigation that includes
the mitigation now pouchy as we'll see
also said that we could be completely
wrong right the data is only good as
what we are putting in modeling is only
as good as the data that you put in if
the situation changes then the outcomes
change fairly radically we saw this from
dr. Neil Ferguson over at Imperial
College in London he originally had
suggested that if there was no
mitigation then you could see millions
of deaths half a million deaths in the
UK and then with mitigation it could be
like 20,000 deaths and then he
downgraded again he said maybe we're
only gonna see five or ten thousand
deaths from this but here is dr. foul
he's suggesting that the models are
showing a hundred to two hundred forty
thousand deaths with mitigation now
notice the range on that is enormous
Ramez in an enormous range there's a
major difference between a hundred
thousand and two hundred forty thousand
deaths across the United States to put
this by way of contrast about 640,000
people 650,000 people die every year in
the United States from heart disease
about 600,000 dyin the United States
from cancer the difference being a
hundred thousand and two hundred forty
thousand is basically the death toll
times to from the flu that's about a
hundred thousand in a bad year and the
death toll that is like half of heart
disease in the United States which is a
huge huge number anyway here is dr.
factory saying here's what we expect but
again the range shows how much
uncertainty there is in the modeling and
that's not the fault of the modelers
that's just the reality of life I mean
the data that we are get
from China has not been accurate so far
there's been wide variation in the data
that we are getting from places like
Italy and places that like Germany right
if you look at the actual per capita
deaths per 1 million population varies
incredibly widely right now the United
States has 12 deaths per 1 million
population that will go up because the
population does not rise really and the
deaths do rise you're gonna see that
number go up in Italy you've seen 206
deaths per 1 million population so
literally 20 times as many deaths per 1
million of the population in Italy as in
the United States same kind of thing in
Spain Spain has Italy type numbers
France which is a little bit ahead of us
on the curve
they have 54 deaths per 1 million
population the Netherlands has 68 deaths
per 1 million population if you're in
Belgium has 71 if you were to say that
the United States ends up performing
more like those nations right that in
the end we end up in the 70 range 70
deaths per 1 million population which is
sort of like the countries that are not
Spain and not Italy but also not being
spared this horrific virus then you
would end up with approximately 23,000
deaths in the United States so maybe
that ends up being really low maybe then
is it being really low
but maybe it doesn't maybe it ends up
being about right if we all stay home
and if we all take the precautions now
one of the questions is gonna be these
estimates are made over the course of
the year how are they even modeling like
they didn't break down the model in
super specific detail yesterday at the
White House how are they actually
modeling the second wave right how are
they modeling the possibility of us
going back to work because this is with
heavy mitigation measures now they again
giving sort of the bottom line doesn't
give you all the details that you need
at this point what's the timeline here
not totally clear it seems that they are
using the University of Washington study
as the basis for these statistics that
study suggested in the next four months
there will be a t-1000 death that it'll
peak around April 15th that we'll see
about 2,300 deaths that day well 81
thousand deaths in the next four months
doesn't really much I'm not sure how
that model ends up with as we relax
things over the course of the next 12
months cuz that's what we're gonna have
to do how do you end up with only a
hundred thousand deaths if you have 81
thousand by the end of the summer that's
that's sort of difficult to fathom in
any case here was dr. Fauci announcing
those numbers
they prepare for the likelihood that
there will be a hundred thousand
Americans who die from this virus the
answer is yes we need as sobering a
number as that is we should be prepared
for it is it going to be that much I
hope not and I think the more we push on
the mitigation the less likelihood it
would be that number but as being
realistic we need to prepare ourselves
that that is a possibility that that's
what we will search okay again that's a
lot of hedging right there right and
then that's good I mean the hedging is
good I think then one of the things the
government is doing right now I think
how she's doing this I think Burks is
doing this I think Trump is doing this
is they're saying here's how bad things
could get even with the stuff we have in
place so how about hunker down more
right how about more of what you're
doing right if in doubt stay home is
sort of the message that's coming out
from the government I don't think that's
necessarily the wrong message you know
again I am NOT an epidemiologist well
I'm not gonna doubt the numbers I'm just
gonna point out there's a lot of play in
the joints here because that is
factually true there is a lot of play in
these joints that's why the models are
constantly changing constantly shifting
constantly being revised and updated
even foul she said that right foul she
said the models were only as good as the
assumptions you put into them here is
dr. Fowler yesterday making clear that
these models are not in any way the Word
of God what we do is that every time we
get more data you feed it back in and
relook at the model is the model really
telling you what's actually going on and
again I know my modeling colleagues are
gonna not be happy with me but models
are as good as the assumptions you put
into them and as we get more data then
you put it in and that might change so
even though it says according to the
model which is a good model that we're
dealing with this is full mitigation as
we get more data as the week's go by
that could be modified right I mean in
it so keep that in mind right the
numbers that they're giving right now
are sort of a very very basic guide
they're not the final word on this by
any stretch of the imagination we'll get
to more of this in just one second but
first I can't wait to go blind that's
why I keep staring at my screen without
my Felix gray glasses April Fool's April
Fool's know what you actually need our
Felix gray glasses you're spending an
enormous amount of time every single day
in front of a screen
and that is really wrecking your sleep
rhythms right blue light is necessary to
regulate circadian rhythms
except for you need less of it okay your
favorite devices are a major source of
blue light phones tablets computers TV
Kindles other devices overexposure to
blue light can cause various symptoms
headaches blurry vision dried tired eyes
trouble sleeping it has for me I know
that I am one of these people who sort
of addicted to my phone and so right
before bed I'm checking out the news to
make sure that I haven't missed anything
and then I can't fall asleep because I'm
not wearing my Felix Craig lasses unless
I put on my Felix grey glasses they are
stylish they look great Felix grey
glasses filter out 90% of blue light in
the most damaging range they eliminate
99% of glare for a propriety
industry-leading lens technology only
available with Felix great by the way
their technology is a lot better than
the stuff you're gonna get off of Amazon
for for cheaper those things are cheaper
because they're not as good felix has
proprietary technology that means that
the the glasses that you are using are
more durable they do a better job of
filtering out the light they're they're
less likely to fail you I get headaches
if I don't use my Felix Craig glasses
which is why I use them myself 9 in 10
Felix grey customers report significant
symptom relief Felix grape frames their
hand finish from durable super
lightweight it's Hallion acetate with
over 200,000 happy customers Felix gray
is really the only choice order online
the glasses shipped directly to you with
hardcase and lens cloth included again
you're spending tons of time in front of
screens right now so you can't go
outdoors try them for 30 days risk-free
if the screens aren't easier on your
eyes you can send it back for a full
refund there is no risk attached here
Felix Crimean they make a fantastic
product is durable my kids are all over
everything I own my Felix grey glasses
have lasted the test of time go to Felix
wear glasses calm / Ben for the absolute
best quality blue light filtering
glasses on the market that is Fe Li X
GRA Y gray glasses calm / Ben Felix wear
glasses calm / Ben do what we did start
taking care of your eyes feel better
work smarter shipping and returns are
totally free over at Felix gray Felix
gray glasses comm / Ben that's Felix
gray glasses comm /ban is something you
can treat your eyes and your headache -
in the middle of a very unpleasant
situation alright so dr. deborah birx
she followed up from foul she says yeah
you know we modeled for SARS here right
the Chinese were basically lying to us
and so we were modeling for disease that
really has a completely different vector
than this particular disease I think
when you looked at the China data
originally and use
said oh well there's 80 million people
you start thinking of this more like
SARS than you do this kind of global
pandemic so I think the medical
community made interpreted the Chinese
data as that this was serious but
smaller than anyone expected because
that I think probably we were missing a
significant amount of the data and now
that when we see what happened to Italy
and we hate see what happened to Spain
okay so as we put in new data we change
the model now there is some good news
here ouchy did say in an interview
yesterday that the rate of increase is
dropping off across the United States
which as I say suggests that the the
social distancing measures the
stay-at-home stuff is actually working
it's starting to work not just in the
United States it's working in Italy as
well here's anthony found you're talking
about it so what we're starting to see
right now is just the Inklings and I
don't want to put too much stock on it
because you don't want to get
overconfident just want to keep pushing
and what you're doing you're starting to
see that the daily increases are not in
that steep incline they're starting to
be able to possibly flatten out I mean
again you look at it carefully hope it's
going in the right direction but that's
what we really are trying to attain that
multi-phase component where it
ultimately starts to come down okay so
that that is that is some good news
Italy by the way is starting to see the
curve flattened just a bit Marcus Walker
from The Wall Street Journal reports
Italian authorities believe the
country's coronavirus epidemic is
slowing down appreciably after three
weeks of national lockdown a hopeful
sign for other Western countries that
are following approach is similar to
Italy's with the time lad Italian
officials and health experts said it
will take until after Easter to cut new
infections enough to begin loosening the
lockdown and reopening parts of Italy's
economy Silvio Bruce affair o presidents
of the National Health Institute Italy's
main Disease Control Center says we seem
to be arriving at a sort of plateau
which shows that the measures are
working meanwhile there's new CDC data
that is out showing that the people who
are most at risk are obviously we have
seen this already people who are
suffering from pre-existing conditions
people have chronic medical conditions
like diabetes lung disease heart disease
they face an increased chance of being
hospital
with Kovan 19 and put into intensive
care according to new data from the CDC
that is consistent with all the reports
from China and Italy as well the new
data gives the most sweeping look at the
way cocoa 19 is causing serious
illnesses among people in the United
States who already face medical
challenges the report reinforces a
critically important lesson although the
disease is typically more severe among
older people people of any age with
underlying medical conditions are at
increased risk if they contracted the
virus now that is true but again the
people who are most at risk are the
people who have those underlying medical
conditions the pre-existing conditions
covered in the CDC records include heart
and lung diseases diabetes chronic renal
disease chronic liver disease
immunocompromised conditions
neurological disorders neuro
developmental or intellectual disability
pregnancy current or former smoker
status and other chronic disease the CDC
found of people requiring admissions
when I see you 78% had at least one
underlying health condition of people
hospitalized but not requiring ICU 71%
had at least one such condition compared
to 27 percent of people who didn't need
to be hospitalized in all cases analyzed
ten point nine percent of patients had
diabetes nine point two had chronic lung
disease 9% had cardiovascular disease
there is no report as to as to whether
severity of disease correspondents a
pre-existing condition but with all of
that said obviously those with
pre-existing conditions are at the
highest levels of risk now as I've said
one of the questions about the modeling
in all of this is going to be what is
the time delay factor here so that
University of Washington model I said
earlier eighty one thousand deaths by by
July they're talking about eighty four
thousand deaths by August something like
that and then total they're saying like
somewhere between 100 and two hundred
and forty thousand deaths hard to see
how if we have eighty four thousand
deaths by August and there's a second
wave that that doesn't look really a lot
higher by the time we get to the end of
the year I mean that the fact remains
that we are seeing a second wave of
diseases that are breaking out in Asia
as well and that does raise the question
of how we reopen all of this home and
Jenkins over The Wall Street Journal
asks that question he says he says
experts are now planning ways to get
Americans back to work with mass testing
and mass provision of masks and gloves
second thoughts about the lockdown
aren't to only to economic costs
accumulating evidence seems to show Cova
nineteen spreading to the most
vulnerable from close family contact
rather than casual interactions the
experts recovery plan
tend to be mum on whether the goal is to
slow the rate at which we get exposed or
save us from getting infected altogether
the polling data on which President
Trump made the decision this week to
extend social distancing guidelines can
be read as most Americans believing they
should be kept safe from ever getting
the virus but is that even possible
holman jenkins says if we were being as
candid in the US as they are in
australia each of us might be asking
ourselves the herd immunity question so
I belong among the 60% who need to get
infected or the 40% who should avoid all
exposure until the epidemic snuffs
itself out he says I tend to think of
myself as on the bubble this is right
when we get back to work we're gonna
have to determine who is the most likely
to get the disease and die from the
disease as people go back to work
because this cannot last indefinitely it
just cannot there is no way that we can
be in August and everybody is still
working from home not with the
unemployment rate shooting up to in
excess of 30% that's not going to work
everybody is for long people everybody's
taking salary cuts everybody is laying
people off and you can't just float
people money until the end of time
that's not something that is even
possible and as I say Asia has a new
wave of virus cases that demonstrate
that this thing is not going away
anytime soon according to the New York
Times in China international flights
have been cut back so severely the
Chinese students abroad wonder when they
will be able to get home in Singapore
recently returned citizens must share
their phones location data with the
authorities each day to prove they're
sticking to government ordered
quarantines across Asia countries and
cities that seem to have brought the
coronavirus epidemic under control are
suddenly tightening their borders
imposing stricter containment measures
fearful about a wave of new infections
imported from elsewhere the moves
pretend a worrisome sign for the United
States Europe and the rest of the world
still battling a surging outbreak any
country's success with containment could
be tenuous the world could remain on a
kind of the indefinite lockdown but
here's the thing that lockdown cannot in
fact remain completely indefinite right
there is no way for the lockdown to
remain completely indefinite given the
fact that the Fed cannot just continue
floating people money forever and the
Bloomberg is reporting the Federal
Reserve is now acting as the central
banker to the world by seeking to
provide the global financial system with
dollar liquidity it needs to avoid
seizing up in its latest measure to
combat the economic fallout from
coronavirus the Fed said Tuesday was
establishing a new program that was
designed to provide liquidity across the
world
it was establishing a temporary
purchase agreement facility to allow
foreign central banks to swap any
Treasury securities they hold for cash
so we are going to give them cash
they're gonna sell us back our bonds so
basically we've got Treasury buying back
all of the bonds which essentially means
inflation that's yet another step beyond
the actions it took in the 2008
financial crisis former Fed official Ted
Truman now senior fellow for the
Peterson Institute for International
Economics in Washington says so the
Federal Reserve's credit it is playing
the role of central bankers of the world
rather than denying it and trying to
ward it off the Fed is trying to prevent
a liquidity squeeze amid a worldwide
rush into dollars as the virus wreaks
havoc on a global economy that is
dependent on the dollar as its linchpin
Julia Coronado founding partner of macro
policy perspectives in New York former
Fed economists said in an interview a
lot of borrowing and Commerce and
investing is done in dollars when you
have a dollar crunch it can turn a
recession or contraction into a
financial crisis very quickly because
the dollar shortage can trigger defaults
and deleveraging meaning people start
calling in their loans the loans are bad
people who have have loaned to the
lenders or who have securities that are
backed by those loans start to default
so the Fed is basically inflating well
you can't inflate forever I mean it's
just not possible to continue inflating
until the end of time and that means
that we are gonna have to get to work at
some point and that also means that
we're gonna have to come up with some
new plans maybe one of those plans would
be the reintroduction of masks right
everybody in the government was
basically fibbing to you for months when
they said you don't need a mask the
truth is you probably do not to avoid
getting disease but to avoid spreading
disease Scott Gottlieb has stated as
much who's on CNBC this morning and he
said why are we not using masks look at
the vectors of countries that are using
masks a lot better I think now that it's
become epidemic in certain cities a mask
can be a value a mask has two benefits
one it can protect you it does provide
incremental protection if you wear it
right and it doesn't encourage you to
touch your face the problem with the
mask is when people have it on sometimes
they're more likely to adjust it and
touch their face and then that defeats
the purpose of the mass but the bigger
benefit from the mask is that if you
have infection it dramatically reduces
your risk of transmitting that infection
the mask is going to provide incremental
benefit regardless and I think you know
if we're at the point of telling people
they have to shelter in place I think
imposing a requirement that that there
were masks if they do in fact go out
isn't it isn't that burdensome I mean
that of course is exactly right we're
gonna have to start thinking diff
only about how we do the office I think
a lot of people who kind of can continue
to work for home will continue to work
from home otherwise people are gonna go
back to stores people can go back to
real retail establishments and hell
wouldn't you rather wear a mask at this
point and be able to go to a store
I mean seriously wouldn't you rather
what a mask prevents you from doing is
touching your own face that's what masks
are designed to do and I've seen a bunch
of people at the grocery store when I go
who are either not wearing masks at all
or if you're wearing a mask you're
wearing it over your mouth but not over
your notes don't be an idiot
wear it over your nose that's what the
masks are designed to do they're
designed to prevent you from breathing
out your germs on everybody else
the other thing that masks are good for
is to prevent you from touching your own
nose and mouth which are gonna again be
the typical vectors now you touch your
face there's a better job there's a
better chance that you're going to
you're going to get somebody else's
germs on you but we're gonna have to
think about how do we socially distance
how do we get people back to work how do
we delay this thing maybe the summer
helps us maybe the summer really helps
kill this thing off
but do we start wearing masks again come
the winter at least until the vaccine is
developed I think the answer is probably
yes now does that mean that the masks
are available right now but I promise no
but but I promise you that the mask
development is going to ramp up
dramatically dramatically in the very
very near future now speaking of the
resources the federal government is
bringing all of its resources to bear I
mean nobody again it's easy to say
people expected this but when you have a
federal government that has two million
people in it and when you have tons of
reports each and every day and you can
pick reports over the course of a decade
and a half saying we need more
ventilators we need more masks and
everybody basically ignored them it's
hard to specifically fault the Trump
administration for that now I remember
the same sort of thing happened after
9/11 remember there's a report that said
that perhaps terrorists are seeking to
use planes and then everyone said oh
well oh the the Bush administration
should have known yeah and there are
similar reports during the Clinton
administration and also it didn't say
the planes are gonna be crashed into the
World Trade Center and bottom line is
this one thing the government is
supposed to be good at right there the
government is a giant jumper and a giant
lumbering idiot right that's what the
government is the one thing it is
supposed to be good at is planning for
catastrophic situations it also is
another thing the government is bad X
the government's bad at everything and
when the government actually responds it
can do so in a more collectivized
fashion and individuals can but that
does not mean that the government is
good at risk assessment the government
is very not good
assessment and laying that exclusively
at the feet of Trump is a mistake
with that said supplies are being
brought to bear the US Surgeon General
Jerome Adams said this yesterday people
need to stay at home you've heard me say
it many times we are working around the
clock to get supplies to cities across
the country to mayors and the governor's
but we aren't going to supply our way
out of this problem
the way we solve this problem is by
everyone coming together stopping the
spread by limiting large gatherings by
staying at home um so you know again we
are movable we're mobilizing even Andrew
Cuomo in New York he's been saying the
White House has been very helpful and
I'm sort of wildered as to how the media
treatment works here because the way the
media treatment seems to work is they
praise Cuomo for basically just giving
pressors every day I mean really like
he's doing what he's supposed to be
doing but I don't see how he's doing
anything different than gavin newsom he
just receives outside praise because he
has been openly critical of President
Trump in a way the gavin newsom has not
so i guess that makes him hero of the
resistance anyway here was Andrew Cuomo
acknowledging the White House has been
very helpful here the federal government
is a partner in this obviously I spoke
to the president again yesterday about
this situation I spoke to the vice
president I spoke to Jared Kushner the
White House has been very helpful okay
so obviously that is good okay so in
just a second Morgan gets you what is
important and what is not important
about what is happening in the media
because then the media have obviously
been been covering the wrong kind of
stuff in the angles that they are taking
are politically driven very often in
that that truly is ugly we're gonna get
to that in just one second first I want
you to go over and say Lee Weyer comet
right now and subscribe why should you
do this well one of the reasons that you
should do this is because you can go
check out our all-access okay all access
live it's a lot more relaxed than our
typical programming basically one of our
hosts and Jeremy Bork we will get out
here and we will and we will just hang
out with you for 45 minutes or an hour
and basically just kick it with you
because we're all stuck in our house
gives you a sense of community we've
been getting great feedback on it people
really love it normally would be only
open to our all-access members right now
it is open to all of our members so you
get any level of membership and you can
access all access live asking me
questions tonight it's Matt Walsh
hosting all-access so go check us out
over at daily wire comm if you're around
at 8 p.m. Eastern or 5 p.m. at Pacific
tonight join us on all access live
daily wire.com we had largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
so one of the you know one of the
unfortunate aspects of this is the media
covering all the wrong stuff the media
would prefer to do recriminations right
now then like get the information to the
public about what needs to happen so
every so often you get an article that's
actually useful so for example the
business section of the Washington Post
today has an article of frequently asked
questions about how you a small business
owner can actually get a small business
loan that's good I mean that's useful we
need to know that sort of stuff that
that article by the way does talk about
when the funding will be made available
apparently the loans will be made
available starting on Friday that goal
was confirmed Tuesday by senior
administration officials who spoke on
the condition of anonymity so if you're
a small business and you need a loan
then by Friday they're supposed to get
this situation online the application
has been really stripped down from what
they normally use at the Small Business
Administration same-day approvals will
still be a challenge most small
businesses will take days gathering the
documents they need to apply even the
most sophisticated banks will have a
hard time shortcutting their processes
to get money out the door really fast
according to high Chaudhuri the chief
executive a small business focused data
analytics firm the new loans will cover
payroll costs and employee benefits
mortgage interest incurred before
February 15th 2020 renting utilities
under lease agreements in force between
February 15th 2020 and utilities for
which the service began before February
2020 hey roll cost includes salary wages
commissions and tips capped at a hundred
thousand bucks for each employee it also
includes benefits for vacation parental
leave medical leave sick leave some
other limited benefit categories in some
cases they can also cover interest on
other debts the new loans are available
to any business for which current
economic uncertainty makes the loan it
necessary approved lenders will make a
determination of need for your business
based on SBA guidelines there will be no
SBA separate review small businesses
nonprofits tribal business concerns that
meet the SBA s standard business size
definition with fewer than 500 employees
are eligible for loans under the program
self-employed individuals independent
contractors sole proprietors are also
eligible if you're in the food service
business the 500 employee cap is applied
on a per physical location basis so
presumably restaurant chains are allowed
to get these loans the loans could be up
to 10 million dollars to cover payroll
and certain other expenses or 2.5 times
your total payroll expenses from the
loan period the the sorts of stuff that
could disqualify you
well you can't receive a paycheck
protection loan program loan
your business or any of its owners have
been previously suspended disbarred
proposed for debarment declared
ineligible you'll be excluded if you've
ever taken a loan from the SBA that
caused a loss so we're not just going to
reward you with another loan if you've
failed before with an SBA loan the
application also excludes businesses in
which any 20% owner as an individual or
as currently subjected to criminal
charges the new loans applied across
incurred from February 15th through June
30th the Treasury Department is setting
the loan rate at 0.5% but the cares Act
caps the interest rate for pay check
protection program at 4% so it's
possible the interest rate could
increase over time the first payment is
due six months after it has incurred the
full loan is due after two years also it
looks like there could be some loan
waivers if you are if you the loan could
be forgiven if you cover cost for the
first eight weeks for companies able to
keep employees on the payroll or
continue paying bills throughout the
corona virus pandemic so the eligibility
for loan forgiveness starts a week after
loan origination date so that that is
the some basic infernal ism right that's
some useful stuff that you can use right
now what is not useful right now is most
of the stuff on the op-ed pages which is
mainly directed at playing the blame
game and suggesting that that the Trump
administration is the worst or Jim
Acosta going out there and just sparring
with the president because he just feels
like pissing on the president
hey Jim Acosta and man ladies find you
somebody who loves loves you like Jim
Acosta loves Jim Acosta here's Jim
Acosta going at the president yesterday
again asking useless questions is there
any fairness of the criticism that you
may have lulled Americans into a false
sense of security when you were saying
things like it's going to go away it is
and that sort of thing but Jim is going
when you were spent doing to go away
hopefully at the end of the month and if
not it hopefully will be soon after that
but has what is going on this
as you're thinking on this evolved
you're taking it more seriously I think
from the beginning my attitude was that
we have to give this country I know how
bad it was all you have to do is look at
what was going on in China it was
devastation I'm not about bad news I
want to give people hope I want to give
people a feeling that we all have a
chance okay a couple things can be
trouble ones one Trump didn't take this
seriously enough in early February in
mid February in early March he did not
take it seriously enough that is true
ensure that the the CDC had complete
failures during February it is also true
that as I've shown you through clip
after clip after clip neither did Mayor
Bill DeBlasio neither did Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi who on February 24th
was down in Chinatown in San Francisco
telling people to come on out and party
it up so yeah Trump didn't take it
seriously enough but I have a question
Jim Acosta how does this help us going
forward again I'm just gonna go back to
that question that somebody slid to a no
a NN reporter who is asking Trump a sort
of sick of Fanta question how does this
question help us fight coronavirus how
is that useful now if you're gonna ask a
question of the President of the United
States how about what factors go into
the decision making in terms of how you
make a national lockdown pronouncement
should you be making a national lockdown
pronouncement given the fact that that
Florida and Texas are still not locked
down right what factors go into making
that decision right and if Trump doesn't
have the answer then he's got found you
in Burks right there so he can just go
right back to them but the media are too
busy playing politics it really is
ridiculous by the way so are many folks
in sort of the un-- sort of the
Democratic Left President Trump
President Obama yesterday decided that
it was necessary to sound off about
global warming in the midst of all of
this he tweeted out we've all seen too
terribly the consequences of both would
not warnings of a pandemic we can't
afford any more consequence of climate
denial all of us especially young people
after no ma'am butter of our government
at every level and vote this fall I have
a question like we're in the middle of
global pandemic you think that the
global warming talk is really gonna be
like the thing that we're all worried
about super a lot right now by the way
come on global warming I'm rooting for
global warming right about now to come
off this virus like I'm willing to take
the hit a hundred years from now if we
can have a little more global warming in
like the next five minutes that'd be
that'd be fantastic but when President
Obama is out there playing this game
like his question is that useful is that
super useful
hey Julian Castro
or failed presidential candidate he says
we have an affordable housing problem in
the United States like seriously that
that's where you're going with all of
this is affordable housing we're trying
to find a global pandemic right now you
might want to put your Marxist
backburner ideas on the back on that
burner one of the things that this
coronavirus has revealed is just how
close so many million American families
are to poverty and one of the things
that I think we need to focus on more is
that we need to be bolder when it comes
to housing assistance to make sure that
people can stay in the apartment or the
home that they're living in so we need
to be addressing this right now for the
coronavirus period or crisis that we're
in but also it has demonstrated the long
term problem that we have when it comes
to housing affordability out there ok
come on come on
well get your side projects don't matter
by the way neither does president
Trump's two trillion dollar call for
infrastructure spending
sorry we're too busy destroying the
entire future of the American federal
budget or we're gonna do that over here
so if you want to add like another two
trillion dollars on top of that to fill
potholes I'm gonna go no on that and
meanwhile speaking of New York City and
speaking of government watchdogs that
just are throwing politics in front of
the needs of the American people
New York City's human rights watchdog
according to The Wall Street Journal is
now investigating amazon.com over
allegations an employee of a Staten
Island warehouse was fired for helping
to organize a walkout over work
conditions in the midst of the new
corona virus pandemic according to city
officials the company fired Chris smalls
a stop worker at the warehouse on Monday
the company said in a statement
smalls violated social distancing
guidelines including ignoring orders to
stay home for two weeks after coming
into contact with a co-worker who had a
confirmed case of kovat at nineteen
walkouts did occur at several warehouses
across the country on Monday employees
were protesting what they said were
unsafe conditions for the corona virus
pandemic Mayor Bill DeBlasio the worst
mayor in America said at a press
conference on Tuesday the city's
Commission on Human Rights is now
investigating the allegations
high-priority investigate the
allegations that Amazon fired a derelict
niro do well attempting to organize
walkouts in the middle of a supply chain
crisis in the United States if the
allegations are true the mayor said that
would be a violation of our city's Human
Rights law and we would act on it
immediately the spokeswoman for Amazon
said we didn't terminate mr. Small's
employment for organizing a
fifteen person protests we terminated
his employee for putting the health and
safety of others at risk and violation
of his terms of employment de Blasio has
been criticizing Amazon's work history
de Blasio said we'd all love to have a
time machine and go back and figure out
how to make this work the fact is I
actually think city government state
government agreed to a fair deal this is
after New York nixed the deal with with
Amazon there's an entire opinion piece
in The New York Times talking about the
evils of the Amazon calm by Greg
bensinger
okay I'm gonna go with like all the
people who are in their houses right now
relying on that Amazon truck to pull up
with their groceries have a bit of a
different thought on all of this and by
the way I don't think that it should be
illegal for Amazon to fire a worker for
organizing a walkout in the middle of a
pandemic after offering all workers a $2
an hour increase in the middle of the
vastest unemployment wave in the history
of America and also offering them
protective gear and also offering them
that they get to stay home when they are
sick they get paid sick leave and
telling them that they need to stay home
when they are sick and people at Amazon
like let's not forget what the chief
demands of these workers who are walking
out is twice their pay twice their pay
you know who's how to work right now who
could work at Amazon a lot of people a
lot of people six million people over
the last two weeks in fact are probably
fully capable of walking into an Amazon
warehouse right now and loading boxes so
it's amazing to me that the media will
hold up people as heroes like this you
wouldn't be holding up as heroes medical
professionals who say they're gonna walk
out on the job well our supply lines
matter right now
it's amazing the same people who are
talking about we need to nationalize we
need to we need use the defense
production act to force businesses to
produce are talking about how they're
talking about how it's right for workers
to walk off the job in the middle of
this by the way if the government
nationalised this you think the
government would be a lot of Jacobin
magazine the commies over there
they said that we should nationalize
amazon in order to make all this better
why so that the government can force
people to go to work as opposed to you
now calling for the workers to be
rewarded from walking off the job it's
just amazing and utterly backwards and
the new york times again they have an
editorial today from greg bensinger
a member of the times editorial board
talking about the evils of amazon
talking about how it's terrible that
bricks and mortar retail has been
falling apart and amazon took advantage
okaythen up in for amazon taking
advantage we can't even go to
brick-and-mortar stores anymore you
couldn't get anything
like bensinger says during the pandemic
reliable delivery of essentials like
milk eggs toilet paper cleaning supplies
has been a lifeline for those who are
reluctant or unable to venture outside
their homes Amazon branded trucks have
remained a familiar sight in residential
neighborhoods a competitive advantage of
Amazon's meticulously constructed
worldwide logistics network built to
shuttle nearly every imaginable item to
customers in as little as an hour are
especially evident in this crisis amazon
has pledged to hire a hundred thousand
temporary workers to keep up with demand
several other retail giants like Walmart
and Target have kept pace with
coronavirus quarantine demands by
keeping physical stores open and leaning
on their own delivery networks
well Amazon and Walmart deserve credit
for preparing for calamity some of their
ability to deliver during such a crisis
may have come at the cost of employee
protections ah yes now is an excellent
time to talk about the evils of Amazon
well it is the only company that is
keeping people connected to food good
idea guys really really strong stuff
factories are cutting output we're gonna
lose 6 million jobs in the course of two
weeks and the folks at the New York
Times are concerned that people have
their their salaries doubled in a time
of mass unemployment really you think by
the way you think Amazon has an interest
in its workers dying off like flies or
its factories being overrun or its
warehouses being overrun with
coronavirus I have some serious doubts
about all of that ok time for a quick
thing I like and then we'll get to a
thing that I hate so quick thing that I
like so the w-h-o definitely needs to
feel the heat the World Health
Organization has been a disaster area
from begin to end they had one job here
one job and their job was make sure a
global pandemic does not overrun the
world the United States by the way pays
millions and millions of dollars into
the w-h-o every single year the United
States is the single largest funder of
the WHL we contribute nearly 15% of the
wh o--'s annual budget China which
apparently now runs at the w-h-o
contributes a lot less than that
China contributes like 2 percent of the
annual budget of the whu-oh last time I
checked someone like that well Rick
Scott the the senator from Florida he
says that the w-h-o needs to be held
accountable for their role in promoting
misinformation and helping Communist
China cover up a global pandemic he
added we know Communist China is lying
about how many cases and deaths they
have what they knew and when they knew
it
the WHI never bothered to investigate
further their inaction causes
cost lives that of course is a hundred
percent true
eh-oh is a disaster the whu-oh has
refused to admit taiwan basically by the
way taiwan one of the only nations that
actually handled this thing well it's a
nation of twenty four million people the
total number of deaths in taiwan at this
moment is well under 50 i believe so the
taiwan has really handled this thing as
well as anybody can handle this thing
the number of deaths in taiwan total is
5 out of 329 cases this is according to
world ometer z-- so they have one of the
lowest rates of death in the
industrialized world from this thing
they're not even a member of the w-h-o
at the behest of the chinese government
the WHL has praised beijing for its
response the w-h-o ignored the fact that
beijing lied about this thing for months
as i mentioned yesterday on the radio
show Reason magazine cited a study that
suggested that if the Chinese had been
more forthcoming about this thing 3
weeks earlier it could have saved 95% of
casualties across the planet
the w-h-o has done nothing but praise
China and talk about how wonderful China
is WH o director-general Tedrow sadhunam
get ESS according to the Daily Caller
who won his election to the post with
the backing of China praised the
government's openness to sharing
information about the pandemic after
travelling there On January 28th okay
that was like a week after trying to
claim there was no human human
transmission dr. Bruce Aylward assistant
director of the wao has praised China's
agile and aggressive response to the
virus he's the one who was interviewed
by journalists in Hong Kong who asked
why Taiwan isn't part of the w-h-o
pretended that his connection cut out
and then his biography just mysteriously
was removed from the w-h-o website l
wore a Aylward set at a WHL press
conference on february 27th on a
fact-finding mission if I had cope in 19
I'd want to be treated in China which is
weird since China has apparently been
lying about all of its statistics
so the w-h-o failed at every level good
for rick Scott for pointing out the
United States should not be footing the
bill for the wh o--'s failures here
there needs to be a radical
reconsideration of exactly how these
international organizations are run
because the bottom line is that when it
comes to fighting a pandemic
these are not democratic decisions okay
I can think of nothing less democratic
than shutting down the entire world
economy okay it's pretty undemocratic
pandemic response is not the same as
normal response and international
institutions exist for disaster response
that is their goal the entire purpose of
a w-h-o is to prevent disasters the
entire purpose of the UN is to prevent
disasters and yet these things are
like democracies in the sense that not
the most powerful country like the
United States has the most weight
instead the leaders of these nations are
going to spend their days recognizing
that the US will foot the bill and
everyone else will freeride China will
freeride and then the United States will
just continue footing the bill because
we are supposedly the bedrock of
international institutions well we're
the bedrock we should start throwing
around our weight and the fact that that
the that the w-h-o completely failed in
its one task and we footed 15% of the
budget at the time is a disaster area it
truly is and this has been true for the
United Nations as well
okay the United Nations has for a very
long time been promoting some of the
worst policy on planet Earth we've been
footing the bill for the United Nations
it's time to rejigger exactly how the
United States interacts with these
international institutions I've heard a
lot of people saying the United States
should be more multilateral question was
trying to super multilateral and its
original approach to this problem I
don't think it was do you it was not
multilateral as it turns out it turns
out the trend was very not multilateral
and its failure to be multilateral is
what has led to this pandemic and then
by the way China started its propaganda
effort trying to blame the United States
online and it's propaganda effort where
they sent resources to other countries
like Spain that were complete failures
they sent testing to Spain the test
didn't work but didn't matter the entire
media ran with the headlines only now
are the media beginning to catch on to
the fact that China was lying like only
now it's pretty it's pretty incredible I
mean the fact that the media are only
now realizing that perhaps China is not
to be trusted like so we should trust
the media which blame Trump but not
China and call in New York Times
editorials about the Trump virus in all
of this okay good for Rick Scott it's
time to honestly we need to take a chunk
out of China for this the the
repercussions for this need to be
extraordinarily grave okay that China
just cost the planetary economy probably
10 trillion dollars minimum it cost us
six trillion dollars just here in the
United States so what apparently Beijing
is still disappearing people over there
seriously ridiculous so so again the WHI
needs to be re-examined any
international institution in which China
takes part needs to be re-examined and
we need to start using our leverage in
order to force China into a corner they
need to be put in the corner it's it's
really horrible
time for a quick thing that I hate ok so
there's an article in the Atlantic today
by Adrian vermeulen there's a professor
of constitutional law at Harvard Law
School and I think it is worthy of a
brief discussion it's called beyond
originalism the dominant conservative
philosophy for interpreting the
Constitution has served its purpose and
scholars ought to develop a more moral
framework this is part of the common
good conservatism wing of the
conservative movement there's a really
interesting ideological battle that's
been put to the side obviously during a
global pandemic but it's kind of
interesting and fun to discuss because
it will rear its head very quickly I
think in the near future and that is
there's a side of conservatism right now
or a side of the conservative movement
that basically suggests that government
is there to do the common good like that
government is there to quote-unquote do
justice which if that seems vague and
scary to you that's because it is vague
and vaguely frightening know the sort of
libertarian ish wing of the classical
liberal wing of the Republican Party
says that government is there to perform
the functions that independent society
cannot perform and it is there to
enforce neutral rules that that it that
the goal of the government is to
essentially prevent harms from one
person toward another person on the
federal level
and then when it comes to local
government and subsidiarity when it
comes to me and my friends in my local
government creating rules for the
community we wish to live in as long as
people can leave then you have a little
bit more leeway with what you can do
with government that sort of the
traditional classical liberal view right
that mixes a bit of Baron de Montesquieu
localism with the classical liberal
philosophy of of john locke along with
probably some John Stuart Mill the sort
of non harm rule right that's sort of
the that's sort of where I come down
then there's the common good
conservatism view and that suggests that
all the things that I like right family
and church and marriage and social
networking right that all of that sort
of stuff ought to be promoted by the
government even if that means violating
the restrictions on government the
government ought to be grown now the
most dangerous form of this is being
expounded by Professor Vermeil he or by
by Adrienne Vermeil he is suggesting
that basically conservatives ought to
embrace this not as a legislative
strategy not just as we get elected to
the federal government now we're going
to push laws that that we think promote
the common good which is a sort of lefty
perspective on how to use government
itself but that we ought to use the
judiciary in order to do so which is a
violation of the checks and balances
that were originally set forth by the
founders and one of the reasons that the
founders took a more classically liberal
view of what government ought to do is
because they had very little trust in
the people who run government they
thought that the people who run
government are ambitious check they
think that the people who run government
are incompetent check they think that
people who run government are willing to
use powers in ways that most people are
not happy with absolutely this is why
they instituted checks and balances
common good conservatism suggests sort
of like early 20th century progressivism
that those checks and balances ought to
be put by the wayside in favor of the
common good now that scares me because
to me the government is a giant gun I
called it a giant lumbering idiot before
it is the government is a giant
lumbering idiot so that means that you
really only want to try and lumbering an
idiot awakened when there is nearly 100
percent approval for an action we have
the power to do that through building of
consensus in emergency everyone is on
board right I'm a libertarian ish Reason
magazine is fully libertarian nobody is
calling for everybody out in the streets
and the government can't do anything
it's doing right so in emergencies we
understand we need the government but in
non emergencies we want those checks and
balances to apply Adrian formule is
basically expounding the the opposite
he's saying that we want government to
be able to do whatever Adrian formule
wants it to do today which sounds a lot
like even if I grew the Adrian from
you'll it sounds a lot more like the
leftist version of what government ought
to do stuff I like then like the
principled containment of government for
the preservation of individual liberty
so Adrian formule writes originalism in
the judiciary which is the perspective
that the Constitution itself ought to be
strictly interpreted such that you can't
add stuff to the powers of government
right the Constitution is a document of
delegated powers and it says exactly
what the government can do and then
everything it doesn't say the government
can do the government cannot do that's
what the Constitution is designed to do
and originalist on the judiciary they
say our job is to interpret the
Constitution strictly like any other
piece of law people who are on the left
on the court have for generations
suggest and that we have to broadly
construe the Constitution such that we
can read our own moral wants into the
vague language of the Constitution from
Yool says conservatives should do the
same thing
he says originally has outlived its
utility has become an obstacle to the
development of a robust substance
substantively conservative approach to
constitutional law and interpretation
such an approach one might call it
common good constitutionalism should be
based on the principles that government
helps direct persons association and
society generally toward the common good
and that strong rule in the interest of
attaining the common good is entirely
legitimate
now remove the conservatism part of that
number to read that sentence again and
that is indistinguishable from what you
would read a Jacobin magazine government
helps direct persons associations and
society generally toward the common good
and that strong rule in the interest of
attaining the common good is entirely
legitimate does that sound like the
checks and balances conservatism you
know about the limited government
conservatives conservatism you know
about the god-given rights given to
individuals pre-existing government that
you learned about in the Declaration of
Independence or the Constitution that
doesn't send out anything like that cuz
it isn't anything like that from you'll
says in this time of global pandemic
they need for such an approach is all
the greater again quick quick point
anybody who gives you the cheat it is a
cheat anybody who gives you the cheat of
suggesting that pandemic politics are
normal politics is not to be trusted
anytime a pendant that that you know if
somebody breaks into my house in the
middle of the night and I go and I rack
my shotgun and then I know they're on
the other side of the wall and I can
hear them creeping on the other side of
the wall and so I blow a hole through
the wall to get the guy on the other
side of the wall with my shotgun that's
a legitimate response somebody creeping
around in my house don't know who it is
I can see on my camera it's not a family
member and I blow a hole through the
wall that does not suggest that an a
normal non prowler in the house
situation I should randomly go around
blowing holes in my wall with my
Mossberg okay then that and yet anybody
that's what these pandemic politics
people are saying they're saying it's a
pandemic see how we need government
during a pandemic that means we should
use government like this during a non
pandemic we see this from from Democrats
routinely with regards to the language
of war right away get the war on poverty
is how you get the the war on want
Franklin Roosevelt in his for freedom
speech suggested that freedom from lawns
was a key freedom no freedom from want
is is not a freedom that is guaranteed
by the Constitution made freedom of
speech is guaranteed by the Constitution
freedom from want is something that
should be accomplished through community
and social network and social fabric but
again equating everything to a time of
war acquitting everything to the time of
pandemic is a cheap way to to move
toward dictatorship Vermeil says
alternatives to originalism have art
have always existed on the right loosely
defined one is libertarian Constitution
which emphasizes principles of
individual freedom that are often in
uneasy tension with the Constitution's
original meaning and the founding
generations norms the founding era was
hardly libertarian on a number of fronts
that loom today such as freedom of
speech and freedom of religion well this
is why I have not suggested that it is a
particularly originalist perspective to
for example suggest that flag burning
was enshrined by the US Constitution
like I'm not sure that that
constitutional decision by Justice
Scalia was in keeping with original
intent so I think that flag burning laws
are dummy I think they're
counterproductive but I also am not sure
that they should be ruled out by the
Constitution nonetheless vermeil
continues he says that another
alternative is Burkean traditionalism
which tries to slow the pace of legal
innovation here too the difference with
originalism is clear originalism is
sometimes revolutionary consider the
courts originalist opinions of clearing
a constitutional right to own guns a
standing break with the courts
long-standing precedent say he's
contrasting his vision with these other
visions he says circumstances have
changed the hostile environment that
made originalism a useful rhetorical and
political expedient is now gone outside
the legal Academy legal conservatism is
no longer besieged if President Trump is
reelected some version of legal
conservatism will become the laws
animating spirit for a generation of
more or more so in other words what he
wants is the judiciary to become an
activist judiciary on behalf of things
that Adrienne Vermeil likes that have
nothing to do with the Constitution how
do we know that he is now mirroring the
perspectives of the left because he
quotes people on the left and he says
but I'm talking about a different more
ambitious project one that abandons the
defensive Crouch of originalism and that
refuses any longer to play within the
term set by legal liberalism Ronald
Dworkin the legal scholar and
philosopher used to urge moral readings
of the Constitution common good
constitutionalism is methodologically
Dworkin e'en but advocates a different
set of substantive moral commitments and
priorities from Dworkin's which were of
a conventionally left liberal bent then
he tries to proclaim that this is not
legal positivism meaning that it is not
tethered to the particularly written
instruments of civil law or the will of
legislators who created them instead it
just draws on the tradition of the
Western Canon the inner logic that the
activity of law should follow in order
to should follow in order to function
well as law he says it's not
libertarianism it's not legal liberalism
its aim is not to maximize individual
autonomy bottom line is there's no
limiting principle here this is not
limiting principle is it finally
like legal legal liberalism says
Adrienne from your common good
constitutional and constitutionalism
does not suffer from a horror of
political domination in hierarchy
because it sees that the law is parental
a wise teacher an inculcate err of good
habits hey that sounds exactly like
Barack Obama and his nudge strategy for
what wall ought to do it ought to make
us better people long wall us to make us
your parents ought to make you better
people your religious community ought to
make you a better person your moral
teachings ought to make you a better
person if you're relying on the
government to make you more Allah and
wise let's just say that there's not a
long history of that being particularly
effective just o Authority and ruler
says Hadrian Vermeil can be exercised
for the good of subjects if necessary
even against the subjects own perception
of what is best for them perceptions
that may change over time anyway as the
law teaches habituates and reforms them
okay this is I'm sorry this is dystopian
language it really is if this were
written by somebody the left we would
all be calling it tyranny to pretend
that constitutional that common good
constitutionalism is anything other than
the arbitrary application of government
power to a set of principles that you
like even if I like the same principles
is to completely reject the founding
vision of a limited government honestly
how do you fight the American Revolution
under these terms right the American
Revolution was based on the idea their
pre-existing rights those rice
pre-exists government if government were
to violate those rights it would lose
its reason for being okay this suggests
that the government is basically the
wise teacher so what rights do you have
that exist outside of government our
government is the wise teacher its law
is just changing you promoting a
substantive vision of the good is always
in everywhere the proper function of
rulers no promoting a substantive vision
of the good is not the proper function
of rulers protecting people from each
other is the proper function of rulers
promoting a vision of good is for
parents it is for actual moral teachers
I swear if you look at the members of
government or the members of our
judiciary for that matter and you think
these people also be my wise moral
teachers I don't know who you're talking
about
I seriously don't know who you're
talking about you're high like there's
no other way to describe that given that
it is legitimate for rulers to pursue
the common good again you you're not to
find in common good
constitutional law sure to elaborate
subsidiary principles that make such
rules efficacious constitutional almost
afford broads
scope for rulers to promote peace
justice and abundance today we may add
health and safety to the list in much
the same spirit in a globalized world
that relates to the natural and
biological and environment in a deeply
disordered way a just state is a state
that has ample authority to protect the
vulnerable from the ravages of pandemics
natural disasters from climate change
from the underlying structures of
corporate power that contribute to the
events I honestly I honest to god don't
know what is conservative about this in
any way like in any way verm you'll
finish as in this sense common good
constitutionalism promises to expand and
fulfill in new circumstances and with a
new emphasis the Constitution's
commitments to promoting the general
welfare and human dignity
overall constitutionalism will become
more direct openly more moral less tied
to tangential law office history and
endless litigation of dubious claims
about events centuries in the past
so basically law is arbitrary but if
Adrian formule agrees with it you're
good with it this is just Ruth Bader
Ginsburg from the right and it's no good
when it's Ruth Bader Ginsburg because it
is not intellectually or morally
coherent and it is no good from the from
the right either common good
constitutionalism has nothing to do with
with conservatism it just doesn't not in
the traditional sense it's not Burkean
because it does not it does not
constrain it is it is not it is not
lock-in and that it does not see any
value in individual rights I you
resonates this just because you think
the judiciary should do what it what it
wants to do to protect your values the
same way the Left does then I don't know
what your principle is other than you
like a bunch of things that the left
doesn't and I may agree with you on that
but your version of government should
not be the same if it's just a question
of which dictator controls us I'm not in
for that I'm not in for that game and I
don't think the founders would be either
alrighty we will be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of contents otherwise show up
tonight Matt Walsh will be hanging out
with you over a daily wire all-access
otherwise you'll see you here tomorrow
for all the updates stay safe in there
and hopefully we'll have some more
entertainment recommendations for a
little later on Twitter we've been doing
that a little bit so go check me out
over at Twitter and I'll see you a
little bit later I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis clever and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
why douse key technical producer austin
stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by micro Amina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20/20 while police
departments around the country are
springing child rapists from the slammer
law enforcement is turning a decidedly
less lenient eye on another group of
miscreants Christian pastors we will
examine why preachers are getting
arrested while the criminals run free
then everyone from politicians to
grocery store workers are jumping to
take advantage of this pandemic we'll
take a look at ethics in times of plague
and finally Joe Biden remember him he
launches a podcast and much like the
entire mainstream media he refuses to
mention the meet - allegations against
him all that more check it out on the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]